all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two
all-form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get 20 off when you go
to allform.com
pacman
all right i want to start with a
correction today i always strive for
accuracy and precision and so on
yesterday in my discussion of the emails
i had gotten about kyle rittenhouse's
mom wendy rittenhouse some people saying
david she's clearly cognitively disabled
or delayed or whatever term you want to
apply
um i mentioned
in among many other things that she's a
nurse and has a certain level of
education she's not a nurse she's a
clinical a certified nursing assistant a
cna
and is it clinical or certified a cna
it is not a nurse so
whatever inferences you me or anybody
else makes let's make them based on just
the actual information she's a cna not a
nurse doesn't necessarily change my
analysis okay let's get on to the news
we have seen now
the signing into law
of the 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill that we discussed
last week
um again for context this was a very big
bill
that became smaller and smaller and
smaller down to 1.2 trillion with only
550 billion of the 1.2 trillion actually
being new spending for new projects
which we will talk about in a moment
big signing ceremony on the white house
lawn joe biden could have signed it
earlier but he wanted to do a white
house lawn event with a bipartisan group
of elected officials because yes
remember there were some republicans who
voted for this bill
much to the chagrin of the trump
republicans who immediately started
saying let's get rid of all of those
republicans who crossed party lines to
vote in favor of the infrastructure bill
they had a brass band they had
speeches the associated press called
them pepe speeches and joe biden signed
the bill into law
now we're gonna go over the final
version of what's in the bill but the
big picture here is that this entire
escapade is a humiliation and what i
mean by that is
the stuff we're spending money on in
this infrastructure bill should be
obvious
we all agree
we just do this stuff we're a wealthy
developed nation we have the money we do
this stuff that's what it should be and
instead it becomes months and months of
debate and argument and disagreement and
shrinkage shrinkage shrinkage of this
package
extreme shrinkage i would even say and
this is ultimately what we end up with
okay so what's in the bill
now that it has finally been passed
1.2 trillion
550 billion is actually for new projects
that includes 110 billion for roads and
bridges desperately needed 66 billion
for railroads our railroad system is
pathetic now i know many people will say
david sir we are not a small european
country that can easily be connected
with rail you know new york state is the
size of some european countries we're
talking about a massive country fine
eastern seaboard western seaboard
northeast to chicago area so many
opportunities for a faster modern rail
we don't have it it's pathetic 65
million for the power grid desperately
needed
65 billion for broadband now the the
broadband thing
it's a little bit frustrating
that we already give
breaks and subsidies and all of these
things to these internet service
providers and we still have such crappy
broadband in many parts of the country
and one of the things i like is that the
incoming fcc chair wants to define
broadband as a 100 megabit up and 100
megabit down asymmetrical
we have had this issue time and time
again at our backup studio which i've
mentioned that we have
um i have options i can get a 100
megabit download 250 megabit download
500 i can get gigabit download and i say
okay but we need to upload big files
what's the fastest upload i can get well
sir if you pay 200 bucks a month you can
get a 35 megabit upload it's pathetic
it's pathetic so on broadband we're
failing
there's 65 billion in the bill
how much more money are we going to give
these isps before they actually put
together something approximating what
other countries consider to be
high-speed internet uh 55 billion for
water infrastructure we still have parts
of this country where you shouldn't
really be drinking the tap water it's
horrifying 47 billion for cyber security
and climate change 39 billion for public
transit 25 billion for airports we've
talked about the sort of sad state of
many american airports particularly not
even just compared to other wealthy
countries but even some not so wealthy
countries that have invested in airports
21 billion for the environment and at
some point we'll dig in more as to what
that means 17 billion for ports 11
billion for safety
eight billion for western water
infrastructure uh seven and a half
billion for electric vehicle charging
stations we've got to build that out
guys and 7.5 billion for electric school
buses funding will go out over a
five-year period and it of course as you
probably would guess it can take months
if not years to start certain projects a
lot of this stuff you know one of the
frustrating things is that you have
criticisms from the american right
which can be resolved by this type of
spending but they also don't want the
spending i'll give you
one one example here
they complain about high gas prices well
let's get off gas let's go to electric
vehicles they also don't want to
subsidize electric vehicles they just
want to blame joe biden that's
fundamentally
sort of what it comes down to at the end
of the day
um they say that we need to deal with
the power outages
that we have in different places well
they also don't want to spend money
reinforcing the power grid in the
context of climate change because they
say it's politicizing power and it's
that guys we know how to fix a lot of
these problems
but they just want to complain about the
problems rather than actually fix them
um okay so is this a win yes it's a win
it's a win but to what extent is it a
win
the package shrink shrinking down to 1.2
trillion
only 550 billion is new spending the
rest of it is just funding projects that
are already that already exist not super
exciting the next step
is that joe biden is going to spend much
of this week making the case for that
second bill some people call it the
build back better bill some are saying
it's dead on arrival that there's no
chance but there's now another bill joe
biden wants to pass 1.75 trillion social
safety net investment
climate policy investment if you could
do all of that now we're really talking
about a more serious accomplishment the
house hopes to pass
its version of the bill sometime this
week if that happens then there will be
a question of
is there any way to pass such a bill in
the senate
it's really unclear
it would certainly become a serious
accomplishment if that were the case and
joe biden's going to be in new hampshire
michigan
and some other places selling the
infrastructure plan this week so if he
can get that done in particular before
the new year although
very very skeptical about that um we
would really be talking about a more
serious accomplishment but that's what's
in the bill and of course implementation
anybody can sign bills
the key is in the implementation and
we're going to follow it you know one of
the most
troubling aspects of this cult
that is the american right wing in the
united states
is the degree to which they abandon even
their stated principles that they claim
to hold above all else as soon as it's
not convenient for them to stick to the
principle
if i say to you which side talks about
being the constitutional side as a
matter of pride
it's the american right they say we are
about the constitution we are about the
rule of law we are about uh having a
country that is the image that our
founders envisioned and demanded and
imagined and created this girl
all that stuff okay
but they abandoned it very quickly
one of the
most important
aspects on which the united states was
founded and and really it's why did they
leave the old country and come here is
freedom of religion which includes
freedom from religion as well but
freedom of religion whatever religion
you want to practice
uh donald trump's former national
security adviser the top national
security official in the country for a
period of time if you can believe it as
scary as that is
recently said at an event
called the reawaken america conference
in san antonio texas hor insane event
completely insane event
um he said
listen
we not only if we're gonna be one nation
under god we need to be one religion
under god
what
what what happened to the constitution
listen to michael flynn who appears to
have completely lost his mind if he ever
had it and he's talking they're talking
about the united states of america right
talking about the united states of
america because when matthew mentioned
it in the bible
he wasn't talking about the physical
ground that he was on he was talking
about something in the distance so if we
are going to have one nation under god
which we must
we have to have one religion one one
one nation under god and one religion
under god right all of us together
working what
what
has he seen the constitution has is he
aware of the document which supposedly
he and his ilk hold above all else
almost like a sacred text we have to be
one religion under god what what are you
talking about and flynn has recently
been really upping the christian
rhetoric significantly
and um
part of this may be related to
there are some q anon people who think
michael flynn worships satan
and in order
to convince crazy people that he's not a
satan worshiper he's really playing up
the christian dogma and it's leading to
him being particularly unhinged lately
and remember this was the top national
security official of the united states
at one point in time um at this same
event he also had very wacky things to
say about nancy pelosi and and he's just
like off the rails with very weird
religious stuff take a listen to this
and uh that's a great song if you listen
to the words it really does it talks
about we're not going to take it anymore
the american people are not going to
take it i i literally and i'll probably
i hope that they run the hit tonight
because i just did a uh
a a media hit with uh tucker carlson for
his show this evening
crowd likes tucker
and and my message my message we talked
about you know this nonsense going on
without what i call the uh the
insurrection crucifixion and and uh and
nancy pelosi is the pontius pilot
she's a punches pilot punches pilot
and this is a crucifixion of our first
amendment freedom to speak freedom to
peaceably assemble
i mean it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable as in 40 fact it's been
over 40 years over 40 years we've never
had one person not one person uh held in
contempt or indicted for contempt of
congress in over 40 years to include a
former attorney general of the united
states by the name of eric holder and of
course today if you saw you're watching
the media okay so as you can tell
completely unhinged like how is there
not an investigation going on into
michael flynn and remember that he was
indicted and then pardoned by donald
trump and also remember that shortly
after being pardoned he called for a
straight-up coup
like in myanmar which in this bizarre
clip from the forgotten country event
was referred to as minamar by a guy on
stage remember this crazy incident
i'm a simple marine
i want to know why
what happened in minamar
can't happen
here
[Applause]
no reason i mean it should happen here
no reason right that's right so there's
michael flynn saying there's no reason
why
we shouldn't have a coup just like they
did in minamar which of course is
myanmar
the guy who mentioned it has no idea
what's going on so extremely disturbing
behavior for michael flynn
and probably someone that should be on
the radar of law enforcement but he
seems to really have lost his mind we're
going gonna take a quick break we have
such a packed show for you today let me
know what's on your mind you can follow
me on twitter at d pacman and we will be
right back
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get 20 off when you go to allform.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners like you we have a membership
program on our website we include an
extra show every single day
for our paid subscribers
and we offer commercial free audio and
video feeds of the daily show for our
members we give priority access during
our
viewer town halls the next uh which will
be in a couple of weeks haven't
finalized the date but i will let you
know very very soon there's the members
only newsletter and so many other great
things sign up at joinpacman.com you can
use the coupon code
felony21 to get a discount it's such a
big discount it should be a felony
but it's not and uh you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
so we we've been having a conversation
now
for what a year close to a year a little
longer
about the partisan uptake of the covid
vaccines and one of the most
anti-vaccine groups today with regard to
the covet vaccines is republicans and in
particular trump voters non-trump voting
republicans are slightly less anti-vacs
than trump voting republicans who are
like the most anti-vacs and we know why
this has happened we know about the way
that their view on the vaccines has
reversed simply
because donald trump is no longer in
office and now joe biden is
and we've talked also about the
increasingly partisan
cova deaths where much more now by an
almost 50 percent higher rate
the cumulative cova death rate in trump
counties is higher than in biden voting
counties they're killing themselves at a
disproportionately high rate relative to
democrats and at some point it may make
an electoral difference but we now have
new data and this is going beyond just
the covid vaccine
the
acceptance
of the flu vaccine as we now are getting
into and into flu season in the united
states is also heavily partisan and it
didn't used to be you used to see almost
identical levels of flu vaccination from
democrats as you saw from republicans no
more
we have the data
um and the data is quite detailed flu
shot uptake is now partisan and it
didn't used to be so we have two poles
from flu shot uptake right now
okay
according to ipsos 68
of democrats said they have gotten a flu
shot or are very likely to get one
whereas only 44 percent of republicans
said the same so that's a 24-point gap
between democrats and republicans on the
flu shot similar to the covet gap that
exists a second poll from this year
shows the same thing
65 percent of democrats have said they
did or will definitely get a flu shot
and only 40 percent of republicans
that's a 25 point partisan gap on the
flu shot that's not the way it always
used to be
for example
last year there was an ap norc poll and
it said did you get a flu shot in the
last year
in that poll 58 percent of democrats
said i got a flu shot in the last year
whereas only 54 of republicans did that
was a four point gap
it's almost the margin of error okay so
you used to have almost even flu shot
acceptance between republicans and
democrats
now you have a gap where by 24-25 points
democrats are significantly more
vaccinated against the flu
as are republicans
another just data point about past
partisan gap if you look at a 2016 study
from princeton survey research
you had 55 percent of democrats and 53
percent of republicans saying i got a
flu shot in the last 12 months so there
was almost no partisan gap whatsoever
so in all seriousness
are republicans hurting themselves
electorally because of this if they just
keep dying
it at some point is going to start
impacting your population
um we've had so let's let's talk about
what's not new
science
has had a partisan divide for a long
time so take the issue of climate change
for decades now
the right has disproportionately
rejected the science on climate
including the reality that humans are
impacting
changing climate on planet earth
republicans have rejected that now the
thing about climate is
it mostly affects everybody regardless
of partisanship now you can make the
case well the more we
burn fossil fuels
poor people disproportionately
are downwind from the emissions from
burning fossil fuels so it really it's
causing more cancer in poor people and
to the extent that there's a partisan
divide there maybe okay so you you can
make a case this is just straight up
partisan with the vaccines the
republicans are disproportionately not
getting vaccinated against covet the
republicans are now also as of this year
disproportionately not getting
vaccinated against the flu
at a certain point you're going to kill
your own voters and it could make a
difference now we've looked at the data
what would it take to make a difference
there was this example and i'll talk
through the generalities of it but we
should really look at the data again
back in let me see when it was
florida
gubernatorial election results when ron
desantis
in 2018 ron desantis won by
0.4 percent over andrew gillum gillum i
forget the pronunciation now it was a
difference of 33 000 votes 33 000 votes
were the margin for ron desantis in
florida as governor
um in the year 2018. now in florida
there are 61 000 covid deaths
that we know of
and there are
very serious questions about the degree
to which florida is coming even close to
reporting all the deaths
um
from from covid so if there's 60 000
there's probably really at least seventy
thousand let's pick that number
if they were evenly split between
democrats and republicans seventy
thousand coveted deaths would mean
thirty five thousand democrats and
thirty five thousand republicans now if
you have a partisan gap there if you
imagine well if the florida data tracks
the national data and republicans are
dying at let's call it a fifty percent
higher rate all of a sudden those
seventy thousand deaths might look more
like fifty thousand republicans and
twenty thousand democrats that's a
thirty thousand death gap
the margin for victory for desantis was
only about thirty three thousand ballots
in 2018 so you can very quickly see how
if this continues to go on
and the partisan gap is there on covet
deaths because of vaccination
and we start to see a partisan gap on
flu deaths again because republicans are
now starting to reject the flu vaccine
as well
in florida it's totally plausible that
as a result of deaths from covet and flu
alone it could flip an election from a
republican governor to a democratic
governor okay those are the numbers in
florida we'd have to see where else this
applies
this is a reality and i'm not giving
republicans advice if they're not
worried about this and they're not
realizing how quickly the numbers could
go against them here
it's their problem
uh but you would think even if they
don't care about the human tragedy of
these deaths that they would care about
the electoral consequences that
potentially could happen so that's the
latest on flu shot and we're gonna
continue uh watching how those numbers
uh look
um the latest thing now on covet
vaccines is that there are people
trying to undo
their vaccination or reverse the
vaccination almost as if you were
poisoned and you want the antidote
the antidote now of course this is all
bogus nonsense bs
but it's quite stunning and i want to
talk about it a little bit look at this
covet vaccine holdouts are caving to
mandates
and then scrambling to undo their shots
so there are people who they don't want
to lose a job or they want to be able to
go to
wherever it is anti-vaccine people like
to go and so they're acquiescing and
getting vaccinated but then they are
reversing their vaccine how are they
doing that well it doesn't work
um check this out this is a very good
nbc news article by ben collins in a
tick tock video that has garnered
hundreds of thousands of views dr carrie
madege outlined the ingredients for a
bath
she said will detox the vacs
for people who gave in and got
vaccinated
the ingredients in the bath are mostly
not harmful although the supposed
benefits are entirely fictional baking
soda and epsom salts she falsely claims
will provide a radiation detox to remove
radiation
madege falsely believes is activated by
the vaccine there's about
four different things there that we
could look at
bentonite clay
will add a quote
major pull of poison she says
based on a mistaken idea in anti-vax
communities that toxins can be removed
from the body with certain therapies
then she recommends adding in a cup of
borax
a cleaning agent that's been banned as a
food additive by the fda to quote take
nanotechnologies out of you
in reality in addition to being
potentially harmful as a skin and eye
irritant a borax detox bath will not
remove the effects of the covid vaccine
from your body so it's
baking soda
epsom salt
bentonite clay and borax i suggest
adding in cocoa powder and whole wheat
flour
bake it for 20 minutes and you'll have
some really really nice muffins at the
end of the day okay um the video is one
of several methods anti-vax influencers
have suggested to followers anti-vaxx
message boards are now littered with
users caving to societal pressure or
work mandates
once you're injected the life-saving
vaccination process has already begun
you can't unring a bell it's just not
physically possible says angela
rasmussen a virologist and professor at
university of saskatchewan in canada
detox remedies and regimens have been
staples of the anti-vax movement for
years before covet anti-vax influencers
and alternative health entrepreneurs
promoted unproven sometimes dangerous
treatments they claimed would rid
children of alleged toxins that lingered
after immunization children many with
autism have been subjected to these
disproven cures by way of parents
convinced that they're alleviating
suffering caused by heavy metal
poisoning from vaccines the often costly
remedies have included restrictive diets
supplements chelation and hyperbaric
chambers as well as dangerous home
remedies
um oh and there's more now some
anti-vaxx groups recommend people who
have been vaccinated immediately
self-administer cupping therapy to speed
up the removal of vax content including
first making small incisions on the
injection site with a razor other memes
give instructions on how to uninject
shots using syringes both methods are
potentially dangerous and wouldn't
actually do what they claim to do
this is crazy this is straight up crazy
um i saw
a tweet from cultural critic
the last real liberal
and arbiter of ideas dave rubin where he
tweeted quote i know a lot of people who
regret getting the vaccine
don't know anyone who regrets not
getting it the people who regret getting
the vaccine seem very confused and they
seem to believe things that are bogus
the people who regret not getting the
vaccine many of them are dead and as i
tweeted myself in response to dave rubin
lots of the people who regretted not
getting the vaccine have since died of
covid we heard
about a number of radio hosts who were
against vaccines got very sick with
covet hospitalized and said i was wrong
about the vaccine get the vaccine and
then they died
it's actually more sad than anything
else that this is going on
and i continue to believe that if at age
10 11 we start teaching kids here's how
you examine whether your beliefs are
justified by facts here's how you
critically analyze messages that you get
in media called media literacy
philosophy
etc a lot of people would be immunized
for lack of a better term against ever
falling for all of this bogus backwards
thinking unfortunately
we have a lot of people on the right who
don't want to teach those things because
they rightly see them as threats to
right-wing ideology the better critical
thinkers people are the more media
literate people are
the better at understanding the concepts
of epistemology students are
it's true they're less likely to fall
for easily debunkable right-wing talking
points and that's what scares them so
much we'll have more on this on our
instagram follow us on instagram at
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with
amanda montel who's a linguist also
author of the book cultish the language
of fanaticism and co-host of the podcast
sounds like a cult um amanda great
having you on i really appreciate your
time thank you so much for having me so
we've talked with cult experts sort of
in the context of whether some of the
followers of former president trump are
a cult we've talked with cult experts
about sort of like what pulls people
into cults and how can you get people
out of cults and and the concept of like
a deprogramming and one of the things
that always happens when we talk about
it is i get emails from people saying
only certain people are susceptible to
cults only so it would never happen to
me which may be true but there's this
idea that there's something specific and
some people just like they can't be
hypnotized they would never be
susceptible to a cult
is that true is there something about
the types of people that would even fall
prey to cults
sure well i was absolutely one of those
people who thought i would never fall
prey to a cult i grew up with a cult
survivor in the family my dad was forced
to join a cold called cinema when he was
a teenager my parents are research
scientists i grew up in a home of
skepticism and independent thinking i
thought never would i join a fanatical
fringe group or fall prey to the charms
of a charismatic guru um but then very
quickly after researching this book i
found that the mythology surrounding the
type of person who would join a cult a
word that really has no heart and past
definition um those stereotypes aren't
exactly true we tend to think of the
sort of person who'd wind up in a cult
like heaven's gate or the people's
temple aka jonestown as someone
desperate and disturbed intellectually
deficient but first of all why would a
cult want someone like that why would
they want someone who's liable to break
down quickly they want someone with an
over abundance of idealism and with
resources and privileges and connections
and stars in their eyes someone who
believes that solutions to the world's
most urgent problems are able to be
found and by affiliating with this group
that they can be a part of that change
they want people who aren't going to
quit after things invariably turn sour
quite soon so um yeah the cult survivors
that i spoke to survivors of everything
from jonestown to soul cycle
they they didn't fit this mold of the
desperate cult follower they were
actually quite wise and service oriented
you you mentioned soul cycle which i
think is interesting are our cults
necessarily bad in the sense of i mean
some people might say like the peloton
world is sort of cult dish crossfit is
another one soul cycle etc
are cults necessarily bad
sure well this is why i decided to title
the book cultish and it's why i often
hedge my language when i talk about this
wide spectrum of culticult like cultish
groups
our reputation that or the reputation
that cults have as inherently sinister
and nefarious is in large part shaped by
the media coverage of major cult
tragedies like jonestown and the manson
family murders before those events the
word cult was not really on the
mainstream cultural radar um and in fact
the earliest forms of this word didn't
even have really negative meanings at
all the word evolved over time exactly
line in line with how our culture
evolved um so at this point the word
cult can really be used depending on the
context to refer to everything from a
group as deadly and destructive as q and
on to a widely followed wellness brand
or soul cycle and that really reflects
something about how fraught our
culture's relationship is with ideas of
community and spirituality and identity
and meaning um but the definition of the
word cult has so much to do with
cultural normativity what separates a
cult from a religion from another kind
of socially accepted group not all cults
that have been
called cults or could be called cults
are inherently criminal or dangerous so
the word cult isn't really enough to uh
identify what particular dangers are on
the table yeah i mean i think it might
be interesting to hear a little more
about evaluating maybe the parameters
you know thinking back to the 2020
democratic primary
i commented on
there seems to be kind of a cult-ish
thing happening around andrew yang for
example who i like and is going to be on
this show next week i was a supporter of
bernie sanders but there was some
cultishness if you looked on reddit and
twitter around bernie certainly around
this candidate named tulsi gabbard who
you may or may not be familiar with um
how can what are the parameters we
should sort of be looking at
sure well
in some contexts certainly in this one i
don't find that it's always useful to um
strive to identify oh this is
definitively occult and thus it is
wildly dangerous but right yes it's good
to be aware of certain red flags if you
will that can signify that something is
cultish and in the book i outline what
these red flags sound like rather than
what they look like you know cult
imagery often involves shaved heads and
long robes and um sometimes a call is
actually a bunch of people in
t-shirts or leggings or you know it
doesn't look like the cult we've been
positioned to see um so
i i outlined many of these linguistic
red flags in the book
and these can include super emotionally
charged us versus them labels when
everybody inside the group is uplifted
with terminology that love bombs them if
you will that makes them feel special
and elite while there are these you know
super loaded terms that lambast
everybody on the outside as
fundamentally inferior in a super black
and white way even just the creation of
a ton of specialized terminology can be
a sign that something cultish is going
on here we all love the feeling of
speaking a secret language um you know
like pig latin on the playground who
didn't love learning that and being able
to talk in a way that other kids
couldn't understand it makes us feel
like we're putting on a uniform if you
will like we're doing something right
even if we're not saying anything that
can't be said in plain english even if
we don't ourselves understand what we're
saying exactly or couldn't define it for
an outsider that specialized terminology
um encourages conformity it in some
cases um discourages independent
thinking and then there's this phrase
that once you understand it you won't be
able to unhear it um that is often used
in cultish groups it's called a thought
terminating cliche it's a linguistic
technique that all cultist leaders from
jim jones to jeff bezos hughes and it
describes a sort of stock expression
that's easily memorized easily repeated
and aimed at shutting down independent
thinking or questioning
so thought terminating cliches also show
up in our everyday lives in the form of
things like well it is what it is or
it's all in god's plan boys will be boys
and q and on it might sound like trust
the plan or well i did my research of
course research to a q an honor doesn't
involve peer-reviewed studies but those
are some examples i as i'm hearing you
lay this out my mind just can't get away
from jordan peterson and um i
you know one of the i'm curious about
another aspect which is whenever i've
i've made criticisms of
jordan peterson in the past a lot of the
emails i get are
i am not accurately
criticizing what he really is saying
that there that actually i'm cr i'm only
criticizing what i wrongly believe him
to be saying and that there really is no
true criticism because what he's saying
is different than what i'm saying which
is sort of indefeasible like if i can
never if you're always going to tell me
i'm misunderstanding what he's saying
but you're actually saying sometimes the
difficulty of understanding what's being
said is a feature and not a bug
right um absolutely to use sort of
circular language misleading euphemisms
that can be really disorienting um i
would venture to think that some of his
followers are confused some of the time
but they just have this sort of
unquestioned worshipping um of him and
yeah that completely sounds like a form
of a thought terminating cliche it
sounds not unlike when new agers or um
keith renery if those who are familiar
with nexium would dismiss a valid doubt
or or concern as a limiting belief oh
that's just your mind limiting you from
being able to understand yeah or or
that's a suppressive thought from the
church of scientology or there's a lot
of analogies to that so
in the world of um changing people's
minds there's this idea that just giving
people facts doesn't get them to change
their minds it often kind of makes them
plant their their feet in the sand or
dig their head in the sand whatever
metaphor analogy you want to use yeah um
what when it comes to getting someone
out of a cult particularly the more
serious ones that that are more
dangerous i guess we would say
what what works and what doesn't work it
seems just saying you're in a cult is
not likely to be very effective
yeah yeah so i'm not a deprogrammer or a
mental health counselor this isn't my
expertise actually like shaking people
and snapping them out of it um but yes
from talking to so many experts what i
can more easily say is what's not
effective um as tempting as it is to
look someone in the eye and tell them
you're an occult you're brainwashed um
those things are not effective that just
works to alienate that person because of
course they think that you're in a cult
and you're brainwashed um brainwashed is
also
really nothing but a metaphor um and is
a term that's often used as a
thought-terming cliche in itself
sometimes just to write off someone as
hopeless and mind-controlled so as
tempting as it is to use phrases like
that they're not super effective um and
also if you're talking to like a q an
honor or an anti-vaxxer or a conspiracy
if folks are familiar with that term the
portmanteau of conspiracy theory and
spirituality um if you try to you know
unpack their logic by citing you know
some of these more peer-reviewed studies
or studies from an institution that
they've been led to believe
is
fundamentally flawed or controlled by
this evil cabal of elites they're going
to feel fundamentally misunderstood by
you um so if it feels like safe and
healthy for you to keep this person in
your life i would say you know have
as much or as little of an outside
influence on them as you can just by
existing maybe use the socratic method
to poke holes in their logic via
questions but indeed like facts don't
change people's minds um and so you just
have to hope that they'll come to
reality on their own and eventually come
safe safely home in terms of the
motivation or what can be appealing
about being in cults or cultish groups
when we think about conspiracy theories
it seems one of the things that's often
appealing to people is that the
conspiracy theory
is a simpler explanation that often
points to more control over what happens
in our lives rather than less where like
if there's random unpredictable horrible
events
that can be a lot scarier than someone
planned this thing and it's just like
this is the person that did it and we
knew it was going to happen they knew it
was going to happen it's just that's
what it is is there an aspect of that
that applies to the attractiveness of
cults
yeah well colton conspiracy theories
really go hand in hand because they
create that us versus them binary and
they do a lot of simplifying of logic
and of rhetoric um but absolutely i mean
cultists and conspiratorial belief these
things tend to spike during times of
cultural turbulence and turmoil that's
what we saw in the 60s and 70s with the
vietnam war and the civil rights
movement the kennedy assassinations
people were feeling sort of
existentially high and dry and the
reason why the united states even though
it's a developed country is so religious
compared to other nations that have you
know high life expectancies and high
education levels is in part because we
have so few safety nets social safety
nets that are there to catch us when we
get sick or lose our jobs we're left
feeling very much all on our own in this
culture and so we end up mistrusting
mainstream institutions and turning
toward alternative groups for closure
and answers and security and some of
those groups are relatively harmless or
even positive but there are a lot of
people who are willing to step in and
take advantage of people's
vulnerabilities that's interesting and
so the
it seems that a lot of the same um
emotional circumstances and economic
circumstances that we talk about in
connection with so many different uh
aspects of society
point in this in this very same
direction it goes back to some of that
underlying structure so to speak
oh absolutely i mean there's a reason
why the united states and cultists tend
to have this pretty consistent
relationship we always have
that's fascinating um the book is
cultish the language of fanaticism we've
been speaking with author of the book
amanda montel who also co-hosts the
podcast sounds like a cult amanda really
a pleasure having you on i appreciate
your time today yeah of course thank you
so much for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i want to share a story
with you that
really had me cracking up when i was
reading it this morning you guys may
know about fox news host maria bartoromo
i've talked about her before and for me
one of the most interesting things about
maria bartoromo who now is just a total
pro-trump propagandist on fox news and
fox business is that she used to be a
really good reporter when i was in my
teens and started following the stock
market
and casually getting into trading stocks
and whatnot i would watch cnbc i thought
i was cool watching cnbc
and maria bartoroma would be on there
and she'd be reporting from the floor of
the new york stock exchange first woman
to do so doing really good interviews
with ceos holding people accountable
asking tough questions and she was
really a very interesting journalist and
reporter
and over the last few years either
because of something that happened
mentally or because
she really liked the idea of being in
trump's good graces and having direct
access to a president or whatever
she became an uncontrolled unflinching
pro-trump brown-nosing sycophant
and it turns out that it's not just a
character that she plays on the air
there is uh there are new revelations
from this upcoming jonathan carl book
we've told you about the book already
and there are many interesting
revelations in it
that she actually spoke to donald
trump's former attorney general william
barr on the phone
and
went nuts on him about supposed voter
fraud committed by democrats to steal
the election from donald trump she
really seems to believe this stuff i
want to read through um some of the
allegations outlined here new book
alleges fox's maria bartoromo shouted at
bill barr about imagined voter fraud
this is crazy these are crazy
allegations former attorney general bill
barr says fox news host maria bartoromo
called him up screaming about imaginary
voter fraud according to his account in
a new book
betrayal by abc's chief washington
correspondent john carl highlights
bartoromo's damaging role as promoter of
reckless lies about the election
in the book book which comes out today
carl writes that quote bartoromo had
once been a widely respected
trailblazing financial journalist ah
here's the things i said she was the
first television reporter to report live
from the floor of the new york stock
exchange now she had her own show on fox
news and she was using it to boost a
series of unfounded allegations designed
to overturn a presidential election as
president donald trump frequently
praised her granted her interviews
um
okay on sunday november 8th
one day after fox and all the major
networks said joe biden was
president-elect bartoromo used her
sunday show on the network to highlight
the most outlandish allegations of
election fraud through an interview with
sydney powell remember sydney powell
that completely cuckoo for cocopuff's
attorney powell delivered a
a fevered rant karl road and bartoromo
didn't expect
express one ounce of skepticism it was
all a lie he wrote but sidney powell's
deranged theories would have never taken
hold if there weren't people in
positions of power and influence who had
promoted them people like maria
bartoromo
bartoromo comes up several times in
betrayal in mid-november according to
the book bartoromo called barr to
complain that the doj hadn't done
anything to stop the democrats from
stealing the election
listen to this she called me up and she
was screaming barr told carl on the
record i yelled back at her
she's lost it
can you imagine the gall of calling up
the attorney general and saying you're
not doing anything to stop this voter
fraud which doesn't exist of course
um
carl said he reached out to bartoromo
for a response because after all it's
highly inappropriate for a journalist to
call the attorney general and demand he
do something related to a criminal
investigation bartoromo did not respond
but a fox news spokesperson did get back
to me and denied barr's account of the
conversation on bartoromo's behalf
through this
the fox spokesperson bartoromo claimed
barr was the aggressive one yelling and
cursing during the call well he'd be
justified in doing so if maria bartoromo
is calling you up and saying what the
hell are you doing fox reiterated the
same statement in a response to a cnn
business inquiry on sunday
later in the book carl described
bartoromo's program as a shortcut to
trump saying that powell had a reliable
platform that ensured she could speak
directly to the president powell's
interviews with barto romo caught
trump's attention and gave her a direct
line to the white house what an insane
situation that trump white house was in
those last few months like it was a
crazy administration throughout
but in particular
once the election took place and once it
became clear that joe biden was going to
be the next president all the stops were
pulled out all all hell broke loose
trump having off the record meetings
specifically to circumvent presidential
records rules um fox reporters calling
up the attorney general and demanding
that they investigate something that a
reporter thinks they can tell the
attorney general to do
lawyers like sydney powell using the
media to try to speak to donald trump
because donald trump is known to watch
tv all day every day just a complete
uh um
it's almost like a childish romper room
of sorts it's hard to even know how to
describe it and of course
wrapped up in all of this
are all sorts of possible potential
crimes
many of which are being investigated in
georgia by the southern district of new
york
maybe at the federal level and hopefully
we'll find out even 10 of it i continue
to think that actually the further we
get from the trump presidency uh the
more a lot of this stuff is going to be
buried and we're never really going to
know the full scope of it i want to
follow up a little bit about the uh
accused criminals
who participated in
rioting
destruction of property
sometimes violence against individuals
on january 6 2021 uh colloquially known
as the trump riots you know um the
writers
were overwhelmingly from a political
movement that claims to be about the
rule of law
and following the rules
and doing what the law prescribes
and yet
they broke the law
they broke the law
by trespassing they broke the law with
vandalism and uh entering
the uh capitol building they broke the
law in some cases by attacking police
officers they broke the law in some
cases by stealing things from the
capital
some of them also destroyed the property
of media outlets outside the capitol
they broke the law in many different
ways but
once you are accused of breaking the law
they believe in due process and of
course due process includes
both sides of it it includes due process
by those prosecuting you and law
enforcement but it also includes
facing the charges against you and
fighting them as you are able to do and
given a right to do with appropriate
counsel through the judicial system but
they're not all doing that either after
allegedly breaking the law on january
6th
at least one individual
has fled the country and is now
desperately asking belarus an
authoritarian state at this point in its
own right
for asylum for cover in order to avoid
facing charges here in the united states
this is an extraordinary story
a guy named evan newman from california
has uh started to
plead
with belarus on bella russian state tv
to let him avoid justice here in the
united states this is wild and we're
going to look at a video of this
evan newman is wanted in the u.s on six
criminal charges related to the
attempted insurrection on january 6th
including two felonies for assaulting an
officer now remember the right claims to
be about support the police law and
order due process so
guys accused of assaulting officers the
right should be saying oh this guy's got
to be held accountable
this guy is now trying to avoid even
facing justice wait that's not law and
order
he was featured in the bella russian
state tv special goodbye america he
recounted a treasure treacherous journey
through forested borderlands that landed
him in minsk and expressed his
unwillingness to face justice in the us
newman says he's seeking political
asylum in belarus because the u.s in his
opinion is no longer a country of law
and order
think about that think about that for a
second they say they are about law and
order they then break the law
and say i'm going to flee justice
because my prosecution is no longer law
and order
what
this is another example of these are our
principles and they are so important
until they're no longer convenient for
us
check out this video this video is
from i believe i24 news
and this special where evan newman is
pleading for asylum in belarus to avoid
justice it's obviously not in english so
this is sort of like a dubbed
it'll give you a sense of what's going
on let's take a look
for america's critics the january 6 riot
at the us capital was already a
propaganda coup
casting the nation as chaotic and
violent
[Applause]
but the bizarre appearance of evan
newman an accused capital rioter from
california seeking asylum in belarus
right one of the world's most
authoritarian dictatorships was more
than the regime here could have hoped
[Music]
this is their heavily promoted news
special dubbed goodbye america on
belarussian state tv
it's also funny how these very same law
and order people who broke the law
allegedly and then are fleeing justice
they also claim to be all about america
except they seem to not understand their
role in furthering anti-american
propaganda by showing up in belarus and
demanding asylum to avoid actually
facing justice in the united states the
u.s is now settling scores the anchor
says with opponents of the u.s regime
newman himself being interviewed about
how he got here apparently by crossing
the border illegally through snake
infested swamps by the way
they also say you got to come in legally
but he has abandoned that principle and
crossed into belarus illegally but says
it's justified because the law and order
charges against him he feels are bogus
and of course why he came
he speaks english but he's voiced over
in russian so it's hard to hear his
actual words
they released a picture of me
he says his photo was put on an fbi
wanted list that's true but his next
claim isn't what happened to other
people there
what do you think they do with people
like me
they're kept in solitary confinement for
eight months at a time and beaten
torture is a common thing he explains to
the bella russian reporter torture is of
course illegal in the united states what
is true is that newman faces multiple
criminal charges in the u.s for his
alleged role in the january 6th
insurrection prosecutors say he taunted
and screamed at police before donning a
gas mask and threatening officers
according to court papers police body
camera footage showed newman pushing a
metal barricade into a police line
before punching two officers with his
fist
i didn't decide
he doesn't even deny his taking part
and we were invited to come in but we
were there because all right it's just
absolutely disgusting so listen another
one of these examples every principle is
abandoned immigration must be legal
goes illegally to belarus
law and order must be followed
commits alleged crimes which are on
video on january 6th we must face
justice and due process and all of this
different stuff
flees as a fugitive to a different
country
all of these principles mean nothing to
them they mean nothing when the rubber
hits the road and this is just another
example we've got a voicemail number
2192 david p here's a great voicemail
but it actually there's something sad in
it i have to tell you take a listen to
this
mr pacman this is aaron from boise yeah
i heard your uh
show today and i just wanted to say that
you missed your calling as a
impersonator here alex jones was
off the charts my friend
so listen we we we can't find my
impression i recently did an impression
of alex jones i remember doing it where
i was saying you know doing the whole uh
that that weird uh conspiratorial lisp
the frogs and all that stuff
we can't find it i don't remember did i
do it on a live stream did i do it in a
youtube clip if you know where that alex
jones impression is we want to clip it
we think it would do well on social
media we just can't find it so please
let me know speaking of alex jones he's
been found liable for defamation in the
sandy hook hoax case we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show and so
many other great stories
sign up at joinpackman.com
i'll see you on the bonus show today
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
all form is the easiest way to customize
your own premium sofa i have two all
form sofas at home love them both go
customize your sofa shipping is fast and
free and you'll get twenty percent off
when you go to all form dot com slash
pacman